season five of the flash came to an end
on May 14th 2019 its 22nd episode titled
legacy left fans morning Nora West Allen
all the while saying goodbye to Cisco
Ramon change is in motion and timelines
are unclear but what does this mean for
season six we've got some interesting
theories lined up for you so don't go
anywhere
earlier today you had read
lightning-like thoughts we want to make
sure you're okay to get out there it's
no secret that season five of the flash
was riddled with plot holes and curious
moments so some fans were bracing
themselves for the worst however the
season 5 finale did not disappoint
in fact many fans agree that it was one
of the best finales the series has to
offer it's long been suspected that Nora
West Allen wouldn't make it to the
finish line but that didn't stop the
ants from weeping when they saw Nora
disintegrate into blue Speed Force
Energy infinity war style Nora's death
wasn't in vain though after all she did
become the hero she always wanted to be
better yet she got to meet her father
while getting to know a version of her
mother that was totally Shui but most
importantly Nora helped put an end to
cicadas rain which prevented him from
annihilating a boatload of metahumans
unfortunately for the West Island saving
the metahumans led to the future being
changed in a very unexpected way not
only did Barry and iris lose their
daughter but the Flash's disappearance
date got bumped up by a total of five
years this is what led to Nora being
erased from her timeline but she isn't
the only hero we had to say goodbye to I
don't want the extraordinary thing about
my life to be
prior to the season 5 finale there'd
been rumors that actor Carlos Valdes
would not be returning to the CW series
for season 6 but instead of killing him
off in an act of heroism the CW chose to
give Cisco Ramon his well-deserved happy
ending
Cisco injected himself with the
metahuman cure to get rid of his
superhero alter ego vibe Cisco and
Caitlin's final goodbye was a total
tearjerker but it appears that Cisco
story might not be over for good so some
fans believe that Cisco will make a
final appearance before the series wraps
up its final season so what can we
expect from season 6 well for starters
we can expect the plot line to circle
around the crisis on Infinite Earths
this brings us to our first theory which
has already somewhat been confirmed by
the series showrunners crisis on
Infinite Earths Barry Allen's
disappearance has been hinted at since
the very first season and now fans are
finally going to find out what causes
the expected crisis now let's get to the
question that's on everyone's mind what
can we expect from season six
well according to Todd helding the
season 5 finale was set up to allow a
handful of crossovers to come into play
arrow Supergirl Black Lightning and
legends of tomorrow are all returning to
the small screen and their timelines are
slated to intertwine this crossover will
be called the crisis on Infinite Earths
and is predicted to be the most
astonishing crossover of all time the
reverse-flash is definitely behind the
crisis and be bumped up the timeline by
manipulating Nora West Allen so what is
the crisis on Infinite Earths
and how many of our favorite DC heroes
will give their lives to save the world
well two names come to mind which brings
up our next theory some heroes won't
survive the crisis crisis on Infinite
Earths is a limited DC comic book series
that was written in the mid 80s by Marv
Wolfman and George Perez this massive
superhero crossover took the world by
storm and basically dubbed the creation
of superhero crossover events this
storyline placed various DC comic book
realities into a single timelines which
made it easier for the writers to wrap
up loose ends since the flash plays with
so many alternate timelines it can get a
little
using to keep track of them all so the
crisis on Infinite Earths was created as
a means to an end having all of the DC
characters in the same place at the same
time helped Wolfman and Perez turn their
messy body of work into a squeaky-clean
masterpiece however the outcome wasn't
exactly casualty free in fact it
resulted in hundreds of civilians
characters and heroes meeting their
demise the most famous heroes being very
Alan and Kara Danvers
although the DC Comics end with
Supergirl and the flash meeting their
untimely end it's possible that things
will turn out differently in the TV
series the flash is set to sacrifice
himself to stop the anti-monitor strain
however there's talk about arrows Oliver
Queen striking a deal to save his
friends lives so instead of burying Kara
dying Oliver could possibly be one to
throw in his towel and save the world
although it would be super sad to say
goodbye did the green arrow Barry has
some unfinished business to attend to so
we hope the flash won't be the one to
vanish in crisis come season six hi dad
hi Jon wait there - we're having twins
the tornado twins the flash fans are
curious to find out if Nora's death will
lead to the births of Don and Don West
Allen aka the tornado twins we know that
these twins exist in a future timeline
after all the reverse-flash did mistake
Nora for dawn after meeting her in
season 5 episode 8 now that the crisis
has been bumped up from 2024 to 2019
it's safe to say that iris and Barry
have a lot of thinking to do will they
create the tornado twins while trying to
produce baby Nora before the crisis
reaches their earth or will they hold
off until the crisis is over and done
with fans would love to see Don and Don
make an appearance in season 6
however this probably won't happen if
Barry Allen sacrifices himself to save
the worlds time travel is a tricky thing
and can lead to people are racing
themselves from their timelines just ask
Nora West Arlen still it's possible that
the tornado twins will travel back in
time to help their father win the
biggest battle the worlds have ever seen
so do you think season six will shine a
light on Don and Don's existence let us
in the comment section below and be sure
to tell us who you think will meet their
demise come season six Supergirl and the
flash or the Green Arrow and that's a
wrap
get this video up big thumbs up if
you're excited for the sixth season of
the flash to start airing and be sure to
subscribe to the themes for more videos
like this one
thanks for watching we'll see you next
time
[Music]